hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my flashpoint timeline explainer we
learned a little bit about how the
seasons gonna pick up where all the
characters are gonna be so here we go
let's start with the big stuff first
everyone's asking like how long is
flashpoint going to last till berry goes
back fixes things and then everything
goes back to normal
well they've actually said something
about that they said it's not gonna last
as long as you think it's gonna last in
that after it's all over some of the
changes the flashpoint changes will
stick like they won't roll back every
single thing that happens because a
flashpoint meaning that like wall-e will
still be kid flash when Barry fixes
things the new black flash will still be
around like the black racer or inertia
or whatever his name is gonna be he'll
still be around so some things will
stick and they've also said something
about the four night crossover so taking
into consideration all the four
different shows in the idea that
Supergirl is still stuck in her own
separate universe and they might want to
merge her earth with earth one there's a
couple ways to do that but that Big Four
and I crossover is still gonna happen
around the same time of the year that
usually happens around Episode eight of
the flash and arrow I think that flash
point will end sometime around that like
typically the mid-season finale is the
time for like a big WTF moment or a big
reveal if there's a mystery that you
haven't learned about yet it just feels
like they would want to go into the back
half of the season with you know like
some big change being set up so like oh
how is everything gonna be different
when we come back
so typically like the biggest events are
reserved for premieres midseason finales
in season finales so when they say
flashpoint won't last as long as we
think it's gonna last
I think whatever they're gonna fix
they're gonna fix it at or before the
mid-season finale so more timeline
explainer Grant Gustin explained at
Comic Con that he's been in this new
timeline the flashpoint timeline for
three months which is the typical jump
between season finales and season
premieres it was the same between the
flash season one and the flash season
two so it's gonna be that kind of thing
but the way he said at this time is is
that because his parents are alive in
this flashpoint universe he's been
spending that time with them so he made
it sound like he hasn't met any of the
flashpoint people in this new timeline
he doesn't know that Cisco's this weird
billionaire he doesn't know that Wally
West's kid flash like it seems like in
this moment here like in the trailer
he's seeing it for the first time like
oh my god so just expect them to clarify
that like bearberry is fully aware that
he's changed things when he saves his
mother but it seems like based on what
Grant Gustin says he's not fully aware
of the magnitude of the changes but
speaking of changes like the other
really big question that they've been
kind of vague on they've answered a few
questions as to how this flashpoint
universe has affected the other shows
namely arrow because arrow is like the
closest show and in terms of timeline
they said that it would affect arrow but
in a relatively minor way and it would
be specific to diggle's character so
putting two and two together with things
that they've said you know from the
arrows perspective about what's going on
with diggle's character I think that
they're just using the flashpoint
changes to change diggle's costume so
David Ramsey the person who plays Diggle
said that he's getting a badass new
helmet from Cisco I think it's gonna be
from this flashpoint billionaire Cisco
and they said that it's not gonna look
like the magneto helmet anymore they're
basically using flashpoint to fix the
issues that they had with the magneto
helmet that Diggle wore the other big
things that are going on or that you
know the reverse-flash is a series
regular on legends of tomorrow this
season but here in this trailer he's
stuck in Barry's basement so at some
point in the first couple of episodes
he'll escape then go off to you know to
do whatever it is he's going to do on
legends of tomorrow with the Legion of
Doom it's gonna be totally exciting but
the interesting thing that they say
about legends of tomorrow is is that
because they destroyed the time masters
there are no jean-claude van damme time
cops running around anymore so
time-traveling criminals like the
reverse-flash are just jumping around in
time as they please doing whatever they
want so that's sort of the set up for
the legends of tomorrow plot like hey we
need to still be a team because all
these time criminals are going crazy so
that kind of answers what's going on
with the reverse-flash this season what
about the other characters though a lot
of people were like you know Harrison
wells Jessie quick we know they're
coming back but Tom Cavanagh was like oh
you know I can't answer questions about
what my character is going to be when I
come back just meaning he's gonna be a
different version of his character and
if you've seen my previous videos I've
said that I just I think he's going to
be the original version of Harrison
wells and Jessie quick will still be his
daughter so they'll kind of be the same
people but not really like one big
change I know everyone's hoping for
though is is that this version of
Kaitlyn flashpoint Kaitlyn will become
killer for
because that would be badass I do think
that we'll see killer frost again this
season in some way but it depends on the
shows logic in terms of who becomes a
metahuman who isn't a metahuman because
if you remember in season 2 Harrison
wells had the metahuman detector and
being a metahuman in the DC Universe is
kind of like being a mutant in the x-men
universe you're born that way you don't
get the X gene later in life like you're
born with the X gene it either manifests
or it doesn't so unless they have like
some story logic derp the metahuman
detector did not detect Caitlin as a
metahuman meaning that earth one Caitlin
was not born with the metahuman gene
so just to be determined as to how we
see killer frost again but I do think
that we'll see killer frost will see
Cisco do vibe things but they'll bring
it out in a slightly different way I'll
be really interested to see how they
explain wally west becoming Kid Flash -
but if Cisco is a billionaire in this
timeline that means that Cisco is
probably the person that was responsible
for the blast going off I'll be really
interested to hear about that - that's
like a whole other thing so let me know
in the comments when do you think that
they'll fix flashpoint and which changes
do you think will stick after it gets
fixed
obviously wally west will still be kid
flash but what else do you think will
still be the same after flashpoint is
over as for the four night crossover I'm
gonna be doing a Supergirl Season 2
video real soon
she's going to be critical to the plot
of that for Nye crossover they've
already announced that so I'll explain
that when I post that Supergirl video so
be sure to subscribe to get that and
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner leo Vega you win a $20 Amazon
gift card just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details the
giveaway still going on there's a couple
more DC videos that I want to post this
weekend like Supergirl season 2 some
more movie stuff like we have to talk
about movie flash - I haven't done a
video about movie flash yet so you have
to do attentionally giveaway it just be
a subscriber leave a comment on this
video they'll probably be a new trailer
for the flash season 3 in the next
couple of weeks I know they haven't
posted a Supergirl season 2 trailer yet
that's just because they just started
filming that show so they'll probably be
a lot more trailers coming really soon
where you guys wait for that next video
to post you can click here for my flash
season 3 trailer video and you can click
here for my arrow season 5 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys